le message adressé avant ces deux
explosions annonce de prochaines actions
sans toutefois de précision des actions
en suède mais aussi dans toute l'europe
il faut rappeler qu'en france le plan
vigipirate maintenu au rouge depuis 2005
a été récemment renforcées christelle
meyrals loïc le moigne les fêtes de fin
d'année approchent
comme toujours les clients se pressent
autour des magasins un attentat pourrait
se révéler dramatique
les autorités qui sont sur le qui vive
la menace est réelle notre vigilance est
permanente et nous restons au plan
vigipirate aux yeux le plan vigipirate
maintenions rouge un seuil élevé de
vigilance
juste avant le dernier niveau écarlate
quatre mille cinq cents policiers et
gendarmes sont mobilisés tous les jours
demain brice hortefeux réuni les préfets
pour faire le point sur la sécurisation
des lieux publics pendant les fêtes noël
est une période sensible
noël est une période perturbée propice
parce que les gens sortent beaucoup font
les magasins c'est une période de fêtes
c'est une période dans laquelle on
oublie en fait le contexte de terreur et
évidemment les en liaison criminelle
pour lesquels noël ne signifie rien
profite et frappe une civilisation qui
justement fait noël
surtout que la france est une cible
clairement désigné par les terroristes
c'est septembre dernier cinq français
sont enlevés au niger par al qaïda au
maghreb islamique
en octobre sur la télévision al jazira
oussama ben laden justifie cette prise
d'otages et menace directement le peuple
français la prise en otages de vos
experts au niger qui étaient sous la
protection de vos agents est intervenue
en réaction à vos injustices à l'égard
de notre nation islamique
le chef d'al qaïda dénonce la politique
française en ligne de mire les 3700
soldats français en afghanistan et la
loi interdisant la burqa en france près
d'une centaine d'islamistes présumés ont
été interpellés depuis le début de
l'année